hey leute ähm ich bin martin und hallo klixen
und helmkamera ich habe eine frage an
euch ich hab zwei fragen und die erste ähm
der name klingt nicht wirklich nach keiner vision
und ja naja ähm kommen deine eltern oder
deine großeltern  von und und die
zweite frage ist ähm dein name matkin
was bedeutet das und ähm wie findest du
ihn yeah ähm ich würde mich freuen wenn du
diese fragen beantworten würdest und yeah
tschüss guter mann donal fighter ich lobe dich
für deine englischkenntnisse  Sehr gute Arbeit Die
erste Frage war eine sehr diplomatische
Frage Ich mag die Art, wie du sie gestellt hast,
weil du gesagt hast, dass unsere Namen
normalerweise kein Grund sind, aber wie wir
aussehen, ist normalerweise schwierig für
dich  und deine
Eltern, woher kommen sie? Meine
Eltern, sie kommen aus Äthiopien und
jeder Weg, also sind wir Afrikaner,
die in Norwegen geboren und aufgewachsen sind, eigentlich ist er in
Deutschland geboren, es ist tatsächlich kaputt, also bin ich,
was man einen schwarzen Wikinger nennen könnte, aber ich
kann nicht wieder  Mitglied, die zweite Frage, wo
war die zweite Suche, woher kommst du
und Matcom? Ja, genau, Madcon, der
Name entstand, weil wir uns in unseren jüngeren
Tagen nicht
zu sehr in die Tiefe vertiefen ließen, aber wir bekamen, was
wir im Leben brauchten  ohne
dafür bezahlen zu müssen, nicht wie Gangster, aber wir waren
eher wie Betrüger, wir benutzen unser Gehirn, also
war das Betrüger, und Madcon ist im Grunde unsere
große Hektik. Madcon ist der Grund, warum ich
gerade hier mit Donut Fighter spreche,
also ist es wie du  Versuchen, die ganze Welt zu drängen,
können Sie mir erklären, dass wir
versucht haben, anzurufen, wie ich sagte, ich möchte darauf nicht
näher eingehen, aber dies ist der
Grund für den Namen. Ich werde für immer mit
Ihnen gegen die Donuts kämpfen